well you know I'm a home chef but I like
to make it look like it's super fancy
you know even when it's not and the
number one thing you can do if you want
to impress people at home is put a
little garnish and the best kind of
garnish is a pickled vegetable because
it pops a real punch so I'm gonna show
you how to do it real quick I have some
vinegar here I did rice wine vinegar
because I had it okay and I'm gonna mix
equal parts water and rice wine vinegar
and then you're going to put a teaspoon
of sugar and like a tablespoon of salt
okay and that's going to just come to a
boil so far so easy right okay then I
have over here a bowl of some shallots
and some really spicy Fresno chilies
because I know you like heat and you're
just going to pour it over whatever
vegetables you want you could use green
beans you could use broccoli carrots
pickles cabbage whatever would you call
this a pickling tip I would call it a
pickle tip so you just let this sort of
sit here and how long until it gets to
room temperature and then you can put it
in like a mason jar keep it in the Panic
yes this will keep for a few weeks in
the fridge